So before we get started with the analysis in this lesson, I want to talk
a little bit about the general process of questioning, modeling and validating.
The purpose of the iterative QMV process of analysis is meant to
take a vague question and turn it into something that is answerable.
We start with something that is vague and general.
For example, when will a person tweet next?
And we try to turn it into something that is quantitative, concrete and
with uncertainty bounds that are clearly indicated.
A good way to think about this process is like a camera looking at
something initially out of focus.
Over time, we slowly bring it into focus.
The important thing to note is that this is a process of
discovery and exploration.
Like exploration, we initially don't really know anything about the problem.
It's only through the iterations that we come to understand the problem, or
even what the questions are that we should be asking.
For example, initially we think that the really important thing to ask is,
when will the person tweet next?
But only after performing an investigation, we might discover that
the more important question is, what is this person's immediate social network?
Now, let's get started with a real problem.